بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
عبد الله بن عباس
ابراهيم اسماعيل عليه السلام
كعبه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
اسماعيل
wasم
holy
bless that is today right
صل الله عليه وسلم
ابراهيم عليه السلام
هاجر اسماعيل
was madeعا
made
سوره ابراهيم
هاجر عليه السلام
and
wasquiring from hunger and cing no
so to go between the two mountains
and going to the top of each mountain
and looking out because
‏vantage point and trying to see if
could see anyone or see what was looking
for really I mean she's in the middle of
the desert they haven seen civilization
and their travels there for days but
what was looking for was looking for the
next step that Allah had failitated for
her doesn't know what it is she looking
for it seeking it out knows that has put
something there for her but doesn't know
what it
‏So she's looking
on
look out com
and in the midle of the son
passes him goes up and this times عبد
الله عباس
this thing that did seven times he says
النبي صلى
عليه وسلم فذلك سعي الناس بينهماعي
حج عمره بتين الصفا والمروه
هاجر
[Silence]
يقول فلما اشرفت على المروه سمعت صوتا
فقالت صه تريد نفسها
ثم تسمعت صه اسم فعل امر
بمعنى اسكت صح اسم فعل امر بمعنى اسكت
تقول صح بمعنى لا تتكلم ما في غيرها لكن
هي بتحكي لنفسها ايش صح سمعت صوتا
[Silence]
‏qui nowy
ثم
فسمعت ايضا فقالت قد اسمع
ان كان عندك غواث
فاذا هي بالملك عند موضع زمزم
‏another
and
called out and said
you know who is making that you have got
my attশ there if you have something
up and صلى الله عليه وسلمزم
[Silence]
فبحث
بعقبه
او قال بجناحه حتى ظهر الماء بحث يعني زي
ما نحن بنقول بحش
بحش في الارض
اثار التراب بحث عن سو
جبريل عليه السلام المروه looking جبريل
here
standing where is that
عليه السلام
into the
another was withou
the
ofem
to
spring up out of the ground
she
فجعلت تحوضه وتقول بيدها هكذا وجعلت تغرف
الماء في سقائها
وهو يفور بعدما تغرف وفي روايه بقدر ما
تغرف قال ابن عباس رضي الله عنهما قال
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم رحم الله ام
اسماعيل لو تركت زمزم او قال لو لم تغرف
من الماء لكانت زمزم عينا معينا
صلى الله عليه وسلم
اللهم
[Silence]
قال فشربت وارضعت ولدها فقال لها الملك لا
تخاف الضيعه
فان ها بيتا يبنيه هذا الغلام وابوه وان
الله لا يضيع اهله وكان
مرتفعا من الارض كالرابيه
تاتيه السيول فتاخذ عن يمينه وعن شماله
فكانت كذلك حتى مرت بهم رفقه من جرهم فكان
البيت مرتفعا
فالبيت موجود من زمن ادم عليه السلام
وانما اعاد بناءه ابراهيم وابنه اسماعيل
‏angled
not be
not you because
never
people
ان الله لا يضيع اهله
‏people
where you are you tell ifplaced not only
you
is if of people if you are of people
don't worry about where you are exactly
where Allah want you to be you are
notplaced
even if you are in the b of well or
‏aell
inleess
desert
you are where
you
say fored this place here
will
by this bo
الله
found
all
was and
[Silence]
الله
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يرزقنا
التوكل
وان يجعلنا من المتوكلين عليه والمتوكلات
نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يغرس في قلوبنا
شده الثقه بالله سبحانه وتعالى
وان نوجه شكوانا الى الله وان نضطجر من
قدر الله سبحانه بل نساله تعالى ان يجعل
قلوبنا مستقبله
بقدر الله وليفعل بعباده ما شاء وهو لا
يسال عما يفعل وهم يسالون والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
عليكم